this video we'll talk about endospore
formation
many gram positive bacteria can form
endospore
vegetative bacteria undergoes pore
formation under extreme or adverse
environmental condition this is like a
survival strategy the spore is just like
a hibernation pod the bacteria can go
into a hibernation mode and whenever the
environmental situation is favorable it
would germinate back again
so spore forming bacteria can withstand
extreme conditions such as starvation
acidity temperature and desiccation
by producing these spores
so the bacteria which would form spores
would remain hibernated and alive
and others otherwise the bacteria would
have to die
so the spore is really unaffected by
high temperature or any other harsh
conditions whenever temperature is
favorable back again
these spores can germinate and form
vegetative cells
so now let's look at this process in bit
more details let's say there is a severe
nutrient deprivation
under this situation the bacteria has to
decide that it would undergo a spore
formation or it had to die so it would
choose pore formation
so in this case
there would be genomic dna of the
bacteria which would be
replicated
and the bacteria would be now
forming a axial filament which is
spanning throughout the cell
there would be furrow which is occurring
at a particular region of the bacterial
cell and this is kind of like a septum
eventually the step septum becomes more
prominent and now the two halves of the
bacterial cell is distinct
the left half in this case is the
forespore or the
would be spore
and the right hand side is basically
this poor mother cell
eventually the septum develops fully
between these two cell types
and the mother cell eventually engulfs
this force pore
now the dipicolonic acid helps to
stabilize proteins and dna inside the
endospore dipiccolonic acid gets
deposited onto this ore at this point of
time
eventually
the mother cell dna is degraded
and eliminated right now the spore has
its own dna and a thick coat
the thick coat is actually formed up of
peptidoglycan and this is known as
cortex
eventually this cortex would dehydrate
so water moves out of it
and ultimately
the dipelonic acid and thick peptidon
core form a heat resistant
spore wall
eventually this pore wall
or this particular spore can burst out
from the vegetative cell
and can survive or withstand several uh
harsh environmental situations
now let's look at
how spore is really resistant to so much
environmental uh
situations
actually endospores are resistant to
antibiotic disinfectants physical agents
as well
so let's look at why endospores are so
much resistant
calcium dipole in it which is a
conjugation of dipiccolonic acid with
calcium helps to stabilize and protect
the endospore dna
small acid-soluble proteins such as
sasps
which helps
endospore dna and protect it from heat
drying or chemical radiations
eventually the cortex of the spore
remove water from the interior of the
endospore
and it kind of
helps the spore from heat mediated
damages
lastly there are particular enzymes
within the spore which are known as
which are actually class of dna repair
enzymes that helps
if there is any kind of dna damage or
not so all of these factors collectively
make the spore resistant to so much of
environmental
harsh situations
now this is really important in terms of
clinical setting let's say there would
be an endoscopy where a probe would be
inserted into your elementary canal
and in this situation if there is some
amount of bacterial spore on these
probes then it can actually invade your
elementary canal and
this pores can germinate there in simple
terms it can infect you so that is why
in hospital settings these pores
has to be killed with the help of proper
uh disinfectant reagent such as
ethylene oxide
now bacillus anthracis which can cause
anthrax can also form spores so from a
clinical point of view spore formation
is pretty important
bacillus syrus which is the key cause of
food poisoning
can also form spores and
probably due to this poor formation
the whenever you have uh heated or let's
say warm food the spores still remain in
them they are not destroyed so next time
you eat something from the street think
about this poor formation
other than these examples there are
clostridium pepfringens which cause gas
gangrene can also form spore clostridium
botulinum which causes botulism and
clostridium tetany which leads to
tetanus all of them from endospores
now you understand why endospores are so
important from a clinical point of view
now endospores can be visualized by
endospore staining i have a different
video on endospore staining which you
can click on the i button and take a
look at it but anyway it uses a stain
known as malachite green moral of the
story is the endospores would be stained
as green and the vegetative cells would
be stained as pinkish
so by looking at this stain we can
understand whether a particular bacteria
or whether a particular patient sample
there is endospore or not
now as per summary we can say the
dipyclinic acid helps to stabilize the
protein and dna inside the endospore
that's what make the endospore very
resistant the cortex is the one that
makes the endospore resistant to
temperature the cortex contains inner
membrane known as the core the inner
membrane that surrounds the core leads
to the endospore resistant to uv
radiations and thereby uv stereo
sterilization doesn't work for
endospores we have also looked at many
spore forming bacteria can also cause
disease like bacillus anthracis
refrigerants and many others that can
cause harmful effects to the human
so i hope this was useful and pretty
short so if you want to get the notes
it's available in my facebook page you
can click on the link in the description
to direct to the facebook page as usual
you can donate uh to my channel using
this qr code you can donate you can also
follow me on patreon
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe my courses are present in
academy which is india's biggest online
learning platform using my code ap 10
you can get a 10